hey I've got a voicemail number and you
can call this number anytime you want
the numbers to 192 david p a troll
called in well someone i identified as a
troll called in to say they are mostly
not a troll but they are sometimes a
troll take a listen to this hey David I
just watched you answer my question on
the estate tax and I want to say thank
you for answering it it was a very
thorough answer but I just wanted to say
usually I'm not calling into your show
trolling I have less maybe three or four
trolls before because I thought it was
funny but usually when I call in it is
not a troll I'm have genuine answers and
I just want to say I watch your show
every single day I'm on your reddit all
the time as well thank you I love your
program I love the community that you
built when I call in and troll it's
typically just good fun and I just I
don't know I did it just kind of makes
me laugh sometimes oh so I'll stop doing
that okay but usually when I call in it
is genuine questions so thank you for
taking my question about the estate tax
very very good no my pleasure absolutely
and it's good to know that this is only
sometimes a troll so I was completely
wrong and saying that this is always a
troll
it is only sometimes a troll because
they think it's funny very very good on
today's bonus show a Japanese company is
giving their non-smoking employees six
extra days of vacation to compensate for
all of the five to 10-minute cigarette
breaks that the cigarette smokers get
what do we think about that is it some
form of discrimination we will talk
about it on the bonus show we also are
going to talk about a new report that
indicates that how your brain responds
to certain particular words might
predict your risk for suicide and the
FDA is warning candy lovers too much
black licorice could land you in the
hospital is Pat throwing out his two
tons of black licorice that he just
bought he will tell us on the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership is one
way to get access to the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show is
another way and remember the David
Pakman show now accepting cryptocurrency
see contributions david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency for more information on
that